[Music]
and
you said pressure
you're not sure thank you for saying
that out loud
i really feel like that got us
who the somewhere answers the question
without knowing
in a room of 600 people you could just
be
quiet right like that's what most people
would do
right hey is it raining outside oh no
i just want you to know that i don't
know neither we're on the same page
[Music]
you want to hit my vape pen oh sorry
[ __ ] i'm
trying not to get herpes my back
i've been playing cat and mouse with
herpes for 30 years now but
every night i go to the club i'll be
like not tonight herpes
no disrespect i'm not saying you have
herpes i'm just saying
one out of five people do so let's just
uh let's just all be careful around this
[ __ ] and make sure that
we leave with the lips we came with
answering his phone to the program
really
[Applause]
just for a second
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up hello
[Music]
this is tyrone
listen i am lying in bed and your boy
has just been working me now
[Applause]
honestly you should know about it
and by the way you might want to stop by
the clinic later
say hello to the cleveland improv
you realize that he answered his phone
in the front row
he your friend answered his phone in the
front row
[Applause]
white people feel this guilt and they
just have to agree with the black person
i'm glad you guys don't care
and it was you honestly it was your
co-sign i appreciate you
your co-sign let that know
lugia i don't care
soon i'm hindu so i get another life you
don't
know what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
see i knew you went to my hbc i knew she
went to historically black college
that's the only place you get this kind
of attitude about being like
black son i'm not white i don't owe you
anything
what's friends are cute
for you you see the friend that the
probably get holiday at after the show
she was just like
it's getting rough for her
you don't care that no one likes you
what kind of horrible self-awareness do
you have
they clearly love me more than you and
that doesn't matter
now that we talked back to you about
yoga what you started
oh my god why is this taking so long she
can't just get to the point right
oh you're right that's why you're in the
audience because no one cares what you
think
society has deemed it this way society
decided i'm here you're there that's
what it is
my job is to be funny my job is to cater
to your stupid sensitivities
i'm sorry someone was racist to you when
you were eight all right
i grew up in texas after 9 11. i promise
i took you because i like you
i promise
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] now and make it all awkward next
door god you're terrible as a person
god how does anybody have fun around you
don't tell me why i'm one of my
young man you can't tell me go to the
next joke i'ma listen
i don't have nothing you're the reason
black men they wipe them
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
truth be told i was trying not to cuss
i'm taping this to submit to an agent he
just ruined my take
i think he's really funny but can he you
can i see something with less [ __ ] in
it
yeah so i came up here i couldn't cuss
and i just destroyed you clean that's
crazy right
you could put that on disney what i was
saying
but you're not good at coming at me
though
right you're just talking you're just
complaining
oh my god yo i swear to god i only date
indian women
but if i was black i'd be out i'd be
like you
know
[Applause]
you should be you can behave for one
story
no you can't really do i
have to kick you guys out that would
suck it's your birthday
i don't give a [ __ ] i really don't
it's not that's such a childish
[ __ ] thing to say it's my birthday i
can interrupt your entire show
can you imagine if someone just like
crashed into your car and you're like
dude he's like it's my birthday
so i didn't i'm
i'm allowed to behave like an idiot
you're like okay but that doesn't
excuse your behavior
it's your birthday i know he's going
with what i was saying i mean it's a
same volley it's my birthday
you know what i heard actually is that
on 9 11 it was osama bin laden's
birthday
so i i forgive him i think it's totally
cool
i compared this table of four women to
isis and i don't
i don't feel bad about it what's that
sweetheart
you're not smart
i don't think you're smart i don't think
you're smart
if you were smart you would know that's
what's funny about the joke
that's the exact thing that's funny
about the joke
and i think your math brain isn't
creative enough to understand humor
no no i'm being serious no no i'm being
i don't think your brain is made for
humor
like and you're probably really good at
other things but your brain i don't
think is made for it i'll give you a
chance for the rest of the show to try
to laugh
but if you find yourself not laughing
just know i'm not smart enough that's
what you have to remind me
your brain doesn't work for it it's not
everybody
i'm sure you're really good at
engineering no you're really good at
engineering
ruining other people's nights
um being selfish you got all those down
but humor is not for you
that's fair and look there is a place to
go if you don't like humor
is no you shouldn't go to hell
why would you go to hell that's for
funny people
you're not going to ruin our time in
hell too
how dare you [ __ ] you don't follow me
to [ __ ] hell [ __ ]
you got your [ __ ] minds i gotta deal
with you here and in [ __ ] hell
it's an annoying heckle that i get at
gigs i like it when people join in i
like a bit of a heckle a bit of fun
but the most annoying one i get is when
i've set up a joke just about through
the punchline and someone goes it's all
invariably it's the same thing so it's
where's erlang where's ellen it's not my
like bet noir it's just a bit annoying
where's ellen
who's in your house [ __ ] your dad
go ahead go for it this is your shot to
prove that you can do this
it's harder than it looks on baby
when that pressure's on he's starting to
fall down there that's how it works
god chose me not you
[Music]
she piped up when she heard the words
below me
this isn't your day job baby
let's go back and forth [ __ ] it i've
been doing this [ __ ] 12 years i'm sick
of my [ __ ] go ahead man you
[ __ ] 20 minutes
hiv what are you talking about
you quit all right
[Applause]
all right she comes again
[Applause]
i want to hear that one i think it's
actually good
come on baby let's do this
[Applause]
everyone raise your hand if you like her
oh my god
[Laughter]
no behind you is a male jesus christ you
thought your girlfriend looks like a
dude
the guy behind you jesus christ
listen i know you're a lesbian and
you've never had a dude behind you
before
but there is a guy behind you
i'm glad i recorded this show
[Applause]
am i stripping oh jesus baby
but i need a volunteer you know what i
mean i need a volunteer
the whole table okay how drunk are you
guys already
first of all this is the most basic
white girl table i've ever seen
[Applause]
for one bottle of white and it's like
two-thirds full you're like
just sip it for a bit i hope they're
strippers
is this is this can he see me as a tv
can we interact
where am i
where are we hey happy 18th thanks for
coming
[Applause]
no not during the show what the [ __ ] is
this no
get back to your table who let her out
hey this is your responsibility
you know which girl this is in your
group who gave her even a pen to write
[ __ ] does she know how to do that or did
you write it for her
hey can we get a round of seat belts for
this table over here
i don't know i don't blame him oh yeah
yeah yeah this guy's snapchat account is
just him arguing with his girlfriend
subscribe dude subscribe dude no you're
gonna angry she's right here
no dude you're like the male equivalent
of this why is
that's what you deserve right now